ich bin krank aber nicht so flüssig wie
die heutigen die fresse du laden bevor
wir mit den richtigen liebefeld staaten
bei der lieben freunde habe ich erst mal
einige rezensionen für auf ebay gekaufte
produkte rausgesucht
zum beispiel dass hier das ist die erste
rezension und zwar sehen schon oben eine
normale rezension von manuela die
schreibt super ware darunter elisabeth
ganz unten die schreibt nicht ob und
dann in der mitte schreibt der
verlandung kunde als ich von polizei weg
gerannt bin dachte ich ich wäre usain
bolt seine fans machen allerdings direkt
weiter mit der nächsten lustigen ebay
rezension und zwar diesmal eine
rezension für eine jacke seht ihr schon
er schreibt walla beste jacke könnt euch
hab die letzten stücke wright damit die
dachten weil ich bereit bin mit der das
ich kevin wollte war hab' den einen
stelle gegeben ist noch alles klar
also ich würde jacke dann definitiv auch
kaufen und das hier ist die letzte e
mail produkt rezension bevor wir gleich
mit den richtigen fans anfangen und zwar
gibt er den schuh einen von fünf sternen
und schreibt schlägerei verloren wegen
diesen schuh sehr schlecht ich dachte
metall ist vorne also ja wenn metall
vorne nicht am schuster möchte ihn auch
schlecht bewerten in der tat kommen und
allerdings zum ersten richtigen ebay
fail und zwar verkauft dort jemand seine
winnie puuh nur allerdings schreibt er
in die produktbeschreibung nicht wie
nico sondern wann tue von winnetou pool
und das lieber freund ihr schreibt
jemand irgendeine ich glaube das ist
arabischen nachrichten die andere person
statt einfach j er schreibt wieder was
auf arabisch und die andere personen
schreibt einfach sorry i don't speak
nudeln
die wirklich bis zehn minuten machen wir
nun allerdings wieder weiter mit einer
integrierung sprachen lernen
ihr seht schon die produktbeschreibung
goldkette miese diese king in shisha bar
damit und er schreibt unten eben die
beschreibung schöner dicker edlem
us-pläne goldkette getragen von jürgen
pieper also zensiert der nachname und
mehmet haben sie abgekauft als sie kein
geld bei hatten bei netto wertanlage
top-zustand trägt man sie wird man sehr
stark und mutiger mal guckt automatisch
etwas böse was sicherheit bringt
ich nehme die dann direkt drei mal wenn
jetzt die wahl fällt es wieder einen
chat verlaufe zwar schreibt dort die
person die etwas verkauft wo sind sie
denn sonst komme ich zur straße er
schreibt ich bin in kiosk lotto er
schreibt sehen sie einen penny und er
schreibt okay ich bin in penny geparkt
du bist in dem penny geparkt
dann so aus dabei die oder watt rms
liebe fällen geht es um einen teppich
und zwar um diesen hier teppich mit
kuhfell muster und naja ich weiß nicht
ob die kuh dann so aus wenn von der kuh
dann so der teppich ist
jedem das seine bei dem nächstenliebe
fällen geht es allerdings im rennen
playstation controller wir hier schon
eingeblendet oben
der käufer schreiben ist dennoch da er
schreibt man ja super ist da auch ein
ladekabel dabei also an der ganz normale
frage der verkäufer antwortet wenn es in
der beschreibung steht ja steht nix also
halt leider laufen was denkst du wer du
bist david der den dicken max machen
aber im rl kleine haie lutscher habe ich
doch von allen guten geistern
das hier ist der nächste die bfl handeln
von einem tadellosen iphone achters hier
zum verkauf steht eine person schreibt
aber kein original ist das macht den
akku kaputter schreibt die andere person
ich kann wirklich nicht weiter runter
gehen tut mir echt leid vielleicht hast
du bei anderen anbietern mehr glück echt
sorry und da gibt es eine wendung und
zwar schreibt denn der typ ich wollte
dich gewann tisch ziehen alles super
alles gläubiger
schön dich zu verkaufen sagt hey ich
kann ich noch weiter runtergehen mit dem
preis oder ich kann ich noch mehr bieten
keine ahnung was nach der andere als gut
oliver tisch ziehen gehen die nächste
person will den verkäufer klar machen
dass er das produkt doch bitte für zehn
euro erwerben sollen darf thun whatever
weil ja weihnachten schreibt
dementsprechend das hier also 10 euro
kommen holen heute weihnachten frohe
weihnachten die andere person statt
allerdings nein danke
und dann war ein bisschen abgefragt und
schreibt schlechten rutsch und hässliche
weihnachten bitte wie kann man hässliche
weihnachten haben
keine ahnung aber wissen sie was
definitiv alles andere als hässlich ist
ihr seht schon dieses t shirt hier
hinten mit dem smiley drauf und einem
zitat meine lieben freunde es gibt zu
kaufen verbindet.de marketing at its
best was allerdings wirklich hässlich
ist meine liebe freunde ist dieser audi
a4 von 2011 die 80 kilometer und bord
und dazu steht geschrieben das auto ist
vorne links angefahren was man auch und
auf dem foto erkennen kann der motor ist
funktionsfähig und die airbags sind
gesprungen
die eier rheinbergs ja also wenn die
werks gesprungen sind dann gibt es gar
nicht dass jetzt der nächste liebefeld
und zwar geht es dabei um den unfassbar
hässlichen einhorn für stehen oben auf
den fotos eingeblendet und inventec
steht hallo ich verschenke ich diesen
unfassbar herzlichen wenig dezent
pinkfarbenen einen fisch unseres kindes
er geht nun einmal auf dem trödelmarkt
passte ich hoffe schon dass das kind
diesen wunderbaren schrott geschenkt
bekommen clevere müllentsorgung auf
kosten minderjähriger die begeisterung
für dieses vollkommen entstellte und
sind entleerte aqua ungetüm erwartungs
konform 30 sekunden nach dem erhalt
bereits verpufft war und nahtlos in die
phase des sinnlosen herumliegendes
übergehen muss das offenbar nuclear
anstellte pushen und zweck und
verschenken so 'oh mein gott' krass
geschriebener text und ich kriege jetzt
was keine luft mehr
hier verkauft jemand aus leipzig seine
küche für 175 euro und ein potenzieller
käufer schreibt entschuldigung sie
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer ja wir
möchten das nicht gerne
ok
das ist ja alles geklärt und das hier
ist der nächste ebay favor lieben
freunde hier gibt es nämlich einen
lustigen frosch zu verschenken abzuholen
von qeep 1 meter 70 hoch und ihr habt
das foto noch nicht gesehen und dann das
zeige ich euch jetzt ist definitiv ein
lustiger vor schwache hier nun jedoch
weiter mit dem nächsten ebay fell wurst
um eine pille man collins cd geht ich
glaub mir beide phil collins aber knapp
daneben
und so schön sagt ist auch drin er
verkauft jemand einen ikea schuhschrank
und eine person aus dem ausland schreibt
artikel usd dies politbüro der antwortet
ein fachmarkt arena das hier ist der
nächste fehler und zwar fragt dort eine
person das wifi funktioniert er schreibt
ja okay sagen sie mir eine gute preis-
und ich werde kaufen 540 euro kann ich
noch machen ok haben sie auto waren sie
mir das bringen ich werde ihn noch fünf
euro zahlen weil ich habe eine kleine
baby und keine auto woher kommen sie
also personen will das kaufen kann es
aber nicht abholen weil er ein baby hat
und auch kein auto und sagte ich gebe
ihnen fünf euro liefern
kosten dann auch noch dann schreib dir
eine person allerdings vollkommen sie
und er schreibt einfach ich komme aus
bosnien alles klar
euro würde ich dir auch der dinge
bosnien bringen der nächste ebay wir
hier schon unschwer erkennen könnte es
wieder ein chat verlaufen zwar schreibt
hat eine person halo ist der wagen noch
zu haben hallo interessiere mich für
ihre vw bus er schreibt ja er ist noch
zu haben du sport klose scheitert einmal
ein man entschuldige sich wenig
[Musik]
das fällt ihr denn ein freundlich zu
antworten
hier möchte jemand einen audi a4 avant
kaufen und fragt halo ist das ein
festpreis er stand ja das ist festpreis
und auch ein fairer preis alles okay
getriebe motor gute mutter und getriebe
laufen ohne probleme ich verstehe nicht
was ein auto wirklich ist alles teil
warum willst du dein auto kaufen dinge
waren kann ich erst dann abholen kannst
du heute um 15 uhr kommen geht auch 14
uhr wollte mit meinen jungs heute noch
wandern gehen wandern
wandern
ok wack direkt weiter bitte bei diesem
ebay verkauft jemand einen tarnkappen
auto für 100 millionen euro verkaufe
tankkarten auto top-zustand stoßstange
muss doch befestigt werden und ist dann
auch unsichtbar preis verhandelbar und
das foto sie hat die stoßstange muss
noch brennen und dann ist das komplette
auto unsichtbar ich würde auf jeden fall
zuschlagen wird wird man mich denn dann
sehen
das war geil so wie bei gta wenn das
auto nicht geladen durch die luft
das ist jetzt der nächste iwf es
verstand aus der kölner network group
und zwar schreibt er eine person hallo
netease löse meine herr der ringe
sammlung auf bei interesse bitte
privaten nachricht und dann schreibt er
darunter eine cd bekommt ihr für zwei
euro aber drei für 8 euro also das ist
jedes jahr 1000 was allerdings sind
besserer die letzte liebe freunde werde
euch dieses stört hat und jetzt meine
damen und herren kommen wirklich zum
besteuerten ebay will den ich je gesehen
habe und zwar schreibt dort eine person
kannst du mir die bilder aus dem inserat
auch noch schicken auf dem handy kann
ich sonst nicht speichern dann schickt
die andere person die bilder von den
schulen zwei monate später schreibt die
person story noch da war in u-haft jahr
laden also denkt jetzt nicht einmal was
kaufen kann doch mal kurz
untersuchungshaft war hier seht ihr erst
mal wieder nur kurz die rezensionen
geschrieben und versehen sie schon fünf
sterne gut mir gefallen die extensions
sehr gut sie wirken sehr natürlich zum
rausgehen auf jeden fall geeignet in der
farbe haben wir uns nur etwas vertan
fällt aber nicht stark auf und das
das hat echt gar nicht auf damit den
verschiedenen farben hallo wie hoch ist
die anhängelast bei dem fahrzeug und
normalerweise wird man dann denken hey
der sagt jetzt soundso viel kilo oder so
und so viele tonnen ist die anhängelast
aber nein er ist ihm wirklich ab mit
einem zollstock wie hoch die anhängelast
es dicker ich glaube der wollte was
anderes wissen verschenkt werden vier
aufblasbare ziffern ideal für silvester
2200 wahlweise auch für 122 zum
geburtstag oder wenn die oma 200 wird
oder als geschenk wenn sie 20 in ihrem
freundeskreis haben um ihnen dieses auf
einem entspannten zu zeigen abzuholen in
langen
ja ich habe ja vor einigen tagen das
hier ist darum hochgeladene folgt immer
auf insider ist ein laser luca können
kommentiert mal bei dem foto alpaca lino
wenn ihr jetzt gerade das hier seht
es ist wie ein paar carlino ist
vaccarino kommentiert ein paar carlino
unter dem bild an der stelle wird das
heute wieder jetzt allerdings noch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
heute endlich mal wieder diese neue
folge ebay fans gefallen hatte das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter dem
video wir das schaffen wir 40.000 like
das werk kraft also wenn ihr bock auf
keine ahnung ein paar tagen noch eine
folge ebay fans habt dann schafft 40.000
likes schreibt mir wie bereits gesagt
gern bei uns in die kommentare
ich kann nichts gesagt was ich gerne in
die kommentare schreiben können schreibt
irgendwas lustiges und den lustigsten
kommentar bin ich an also der wird dann
ganz oben angezeigt
[Musik]